hey guys today I will be demonstrating
and talking about one of my actually my
very favorite squad accessory look these
are breathing muscle squats and you do
them nicely and you taking nice full
breaths at the bottom of the squat and
this position I'll be explaining why so
the first thing is they just get you
comfortable a little a lot of people
don't like squats because they're
comfortable so when you get down here it
is much less scary just about anything
the second reason I really like them is
they aid in force transfer to the bar
typically your legs are capable of would
be much more weight than you can
actually swap but to squat a lot we need
to be able to transfer that force from
your legs and actually into the bar so
this is a good way because your body to
complete four high school abdominal
pressure ok needed a break your body
typically relies on incredible pressure
to stabilize your spine and make your
torso rigid for transferring force so
and of course with the same place you're
not going to hurt yourself with but if
you get comfortable exhaling
under a heavy load it trains those
muscles that help stabilize and give
rigidity to your spine - it makes me
stronger and teaches them how they need
to activate and lastly if you're
squatting awful lot of weight
I spotted the sevens 315 just wore me
out a lot easier on your joints than
supplying 600 they in India that's all